hello I would like to purchase a
delicious drink from you yeah I'm sorry
I didn't know anyone else was still here
we closed like two hours ago I would
like a drink have you with alcohol you
must be wondering why thank you for
asking
I've had a long stressful day at the
office crunching and grinding and now I
want my blood diluted my brain slowed by
your sweet liquid caress ah I see
well you know we got a great bar on a
street that does a blood dilution inside
of me is an aching need writhing dancing
years of droughts have caused a desert
and now I stand here Becky cool cool I'm
gonna go make a phone call real quick
the doors of my home have been shuttered
and guess what baby's not allowed in the
hospital anymore and so baby wanders
looking for mommy but mommy isn't there
not at this time of night stand here
wait you know what if you want to drink
that's fine
how could you drink no problem
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you mister I'm sorry about being
so weird I just really needed this yeah
we're still closed